and now an exclusive sneak peek at the
first episode of Mars
[Music]
retrorockets about to fire
we dream
is who we are
down to our bones ourselves that
instinct to build that drive to seek
beyond what we know it's in our DNA we
crossed the oceans
we conquered the skies and when there
were no more frontiers on earth we
launched ourselves among the stars we
chose to do the other things not because
they are easy but because they are hard
the heavens backand a new generation of
innovators and explorers seeking to take
humankind even further
we can push out into the solar system
not just to visit but to stay that was
when Mars became real for all of us for
those of us who were around to see the
first days it was electrifying
the world's leading Space Agency's
United as the International Mars Science
Foundation and joined with private
industry to accomplish one shared goal
to build a home for humankind on Mars
people weren't just talking about the
Red Planet they were making plans to go
there
and after years of training in the
astronaut corps I was chosen to command
the first human mission to Mars
[Music]
like brand-new Cadillac
but that sign isn't gonna last over the
next seven months your bodies are gonna
be exposed to nearly 200 times the dose
of a normal years worth of radiation
exposure on earth
calcium will leach from your bones which
will lose nearly ten percent of their
mass before you even get to Mars there
is no test that can tell you whether or
not the notion of being sixty million
kilometers away from the planet on which
you were born can shatter your mind in
so many pieces some of us if not all of
us will almost certainly die on this
mission might being take off might be an
landing might be in the new world itself
now you all are the bravest group of
women and men I have ever met I'm damn
proud to be here with you but right now
I want you to stop and ask yourself what
really is important to you about this
mission and if the answer to that
question is not the most important thing
in your life then I'm gonna invite you
to walk out that door and go pursue
whatever that thing is and don't ever
look back because no one will ever have
the right to hold it against you
dateless you are go for a launch in
t-minus 17 seconds in Canada mission
analytics executor you have primary
control of all the critical functions
may the ship is yours I am in control
Mars the global event series premieres
Monday November 14th at 9:00 on National
Geographic